[Música]
bienvenidos a la entrevista de france 24
hoy desde bakú la capital de azerbaiyán
estoy con el presidente del país ilham
alíev presidente alí muchas gracias por
aceptar esta entrevista
por supuesto le preguntaré acerca del
conflicto en nagorno karabaj desde el
alto el fuego que se suponía era una
tregua humanitaria que fue firmada ha
habido violencia continua que continuos
actos de guerra
hoy le pregunto este alto el fuego se
terminó de manera oficial y es nulo y
sin efecto
depende del comportamiento de armenia
porque nosotros siempre estamos
comprometidos con nuestra
responsabilidad la decisión de anunciar
el alto el fuego por razones
humanitarias como lo sabe vino de rusia
y nosotros la apoyamos porque creo que
era una decisión correcta para poder
intercambiar cuerpos de soldados
fallecidos y rehenes y también para
continuar con la actividad
negociación porque la declaración que se
anunció en moscú en realidad demostró
que las negociaciones se basarían en los
principios básicos esa fue siempre
nuestra posición el lado armenio siempre
trató de alterar el proceso y trató de
introducir nuevas estrategias a la mesa
de negociación que nosotros rechazamos
nosotros y los copresidentes del grupo
minsk
durante los últimos dos años después de
la llegada al poder del nuevo gobierno
de armenia una de las actividades fue
traer las supuestas autoridades de
nagorno karabaj a la mesa de negociación
y cambiar así el formato porque durante
más de 20 años las negociaciones se han
hecho entre armenia y azerbayán
bajo el marco del proceso del grupo de
minsk
el intento por traer a las supuestas
autoridades de nagorno karabaj o fue un
intento por cambiar el formato nosotros
estábamos respetando el alto el fuego
pero como usted sabe armenia lo violó
brutalmente y no solo engancha el ataque
a los civiles engancha fue un reflejo de
la política agresiva y además todos los
días violan el alto el fuego
esta mañana me informaron que desde las
7 hasta las 9 de la mañana más de 150
veces bombardearon la ciudad de tartar y
acdam y desafortunadamente obtenemos una
víctima entre los civiles en tartán pero
azerbaiyán también ha seguido disparando
no es verdad el mundo ha visto imágenes
de civiles bajo bombardeos en estepa
nackers dentro de nagorno karabaj
primero desde que se anunció el alto el
fuego todo bombardeo por parte de hacer
balance de tu segundo nosotros nunca
atacamos de manera deliberada a los
civiles en ninguna ciudad o pueblo en
los territorios ocupados
nuestros objetivos sólo eran las
instalaciones militares nuestros
objetivos militares han sido
cuidadosamente identificados por lo
tanto sólo hemos aplicado los objetivos
que eran una amenaza para la vida de
nuestra gente y de nuestros soldados
pero desafortunadamente los armenios
están utilizando estrategias para
instalar equipos militares en las áreas
de las ciudades donde viven las personas
entonces nosotros tenemos que
protegernos díaz desde que se estableció
el alto el fuego nosotros nos
comprometimos con eso pero armenia lo
violó así que nosotros tuvimos que
responder entonces está diciendo que no
ha habido ataques por parte de
azerbaiyán desde el anuncio de alto el
fuego no a los objetivos militares ha
habido
no lo negamos pero eso es natural porque
debemos defendernos el alto el fuego no
puede lograrse de manera unilateral de
otro modo armenia tendrá ventaja y
logrará su objetivo y en realidad lo que
están tratando de hacer es recuperar los
territorios que han sido liberados en
particular trataron de recuperar la
ciudad de kastrup pero fracasaron
mi consejo para ellos y ya me dirigí
públicamente a los líderes armenios y
también a la población armenia es que
deberían dejar de tratar de recuperar lo
que ha sido liberado eso sólo causará
nuevas víctimas y llevará al
derramamiento de sangre que puedo decir
acerca de las imágenes de los bombardeos
a las iglesias en nagorno karabaj esos
no son objetivos militares con seguridad
si tienes razón
estamos investigando ese asunto me
gustaría decir que azerbaiyán es un país
con un nivel muy alto de tolerancia que
ha sido reflejado por las mayores
organizaciones internacionales
incluyendo naciones unidas'
pero desde el vaticano
durante la visita de su santidad el
líder del vaticano el papa francisco
abajo él declaró públicamente que el
nivel de diálogo intercultural de
diálogo interreligioso en azerbayán es
muy alto
usted probablemente ha visto la iglesia
armenia en el centro de bakú que fue
restaurada y es protegida con una
herencia del pueblo armenio
en esa iglesia guardamos más de 5.000
libros antiguos en armenio
pero lo que herminia le ha hecho a
nuestras mezquitas lo que le hicieron a
la mezquita de adam a la mezquita de
fusiles a la mezquita de chucha si no
sólo las destruyeron casi por completo
sino que tienen animales ahí tienen
cerdos ahí y así están insultando los
sentimientos de todos los musulmanes no
solo los nuestros
no estoy diciendo que vayamos hecho por
venganza no necesitamos investigar el
asunto estamos seguros de que pasó
sospechamos que puede haber sido hecho
por los armenios para poder culparnos si
fue hecho por las unidades militares de
azerbayán fue un error nosotros no
tenemos ningún objetivo histórico
religioso
entre los objetivos que tenemos quiero
preguntarle ahora sobre el proceso
diplomático ha habido una mediación
constante con el grupo de minsk de la
osce los copresidentes actualmente son
francia eeuu y rusia
cree que esa estructura debe mantenerse
que francia debería seguir siendo
copresidente en esas negociaciones
estamos recibiendo algunos mensajes y
declaraciones contradictorios desde el
comienzo del estallido pero creo que a
causa de nuestros esfuerzos diplomáticos
mutuos logramos mantener la situación
bajo como sabe recibir varias llamadas
del presidente macro ni nuestra última
conversación fue muy positiva
comprometimos nuestros esfuerzos para
encontrarle una solución política al
conflicto
me informaron que francia como
copresidente permanecerá neutral porque
esa es la orden para un copresidente
hace poco me informaron que el ministro
de asuntos exteriores francés realizó
una declaración donde decía que como
franciasco presidente del grupo de minsk
debe ser neutral nosotros apoyamos
completamente esta posición y nuestra
posición siempre fue que los
copresidentes deben ser neutrales y no
deberían tomar bandos porque eso
contradice su orden
a nivel nacional todo país tiene aliados
amigos algunos países con los que tienen
relaciones más activas con algunos
países menos activas eso es normal
nadie lo está negando pero si algunos
países tienen la obligación de ser
mediadores estoy seguro de que ambos
bandos
azerbaiyán y armenia esperan neutralidad
y ahora estamos viendo esa neutralidad
y por eso creo que el problema al que
usted se está refiriendo ya terminó y
podemos cerrar ese capítulo
en entrevistas previas usted pidió una
disculpa de manuel macrón después de que
él dijera que 300 soldados de cydia
habían sido llevados para luchar para su
lado cuando hablo con él la última vez
hablaron sobre este asunto sobre su
acusación de mercenarios luchando para
su bando sí por supuesto hablamos sobre
eso y yo seguía esperando la evidencia
no se me presentó ninguna evidencia y no
se le presentó evidencia a nuestros
otros oficiales
le pedí al presidente francés que
mostrara evidencia
y que organizara un contacto con los
líderes de las unidades de estado
correspondientes para poder hablar para
poder intercambiar esta información ese
contacto se dio y puedo decirle que no
nos presentaron una evidencia
creo que estos rumores también deben
dejarse atrás
no tenemos mercenarios esa es nuestra
declaración oficial y desde el estallido
y hasta más de dos semanas después ni un
solo país ha presentado ninguna
evidencia de eso y además no lo
necesitamos
tenemos un ejército de más de 100.000
soldados y lo que estamos haciendo ahora
en el terreno demuestra que nuestro
ejército es capaz de liberar sus tierras
por si mismo
el ministro de asuntos extranjeros o
janis letra yang dijo que el ejército
turco está involucrado lo cual le corre
el riesgo de internacionalizar este
conflicto se equivoca sobre eso si se
equivoca sobre eso que el ejército turco
está involucrado es otra noticia falsa
turquía no está involucrada militarmente
estamos utilizando equipo militar turco
eso es verdad pero estamos utilizando
equipo militar de rusia equipo militar
de israel equipo militar de otros países
y compramos esos equipos militares a
diferencia de armenia que lo consigue de
forma gratuita turquía no está de
ninguna manera más que política presente
en el proceso no hay fuerzas turcas los
f-16 turcos están ahí fueron dejados ahí
después de que se dieran al
entrenamiento militar
por cierto el año pasado tuvimos 10
entrenamientos militares conjuntos con
turquía incluyendo la fuerza aérea este
año causa la pandemia solo tuvimos dos y
justo después del entrenamiento militar
ocurrió este estallido entonces
decidimos mantener a los f-16 en el
terreno y están en el terreno no están
en el aire
cuántos drones turcos ha desplegado y
tenemos suficientes para lograr nuestros
objetivos
creo que puede entender que esta es una
información que prefiere no revelar pero
están marcando la diferencia en este
conflicto
por supuesto
son armas muy modernas sofisticadas
puedo decirle que sólo con los drones
que adquirimos de turquía
destruimos equipo militar armenio
valorado en mil millones de dólares sólo
con los drones y por supuesto estamos
utilizando otros drones como sabe de
otras fuentes estamos utilizando
artillería estamos utilizando un amplio
rango de equipo militar pero solo los
drones que causaron un daño armenia
valorado en mil millones de dólares y
eso es un daño serio para ellos me
pregunto dónde consiguieron tanto dinero
para comprar todo ese equipo
probablemente lo consiguieron de forma
gratuita me temo que debemos dejarlo
hasta aquí las tantas preguntas más que
podríamos hacerle pero muchas gracias
presidente ilham alíyev por contestar a
nuestras preguntas hoy y muchas gracias
a ustedes en casa por sintonizarnos que
desee con nosotros en france24 para más
información
[Música]